fijémonos en cómo escribir las
configuraciones electrónicas para el
primer periodo y aquí tenemos el primer
periodo de la tabla periódica y sólo
tenemos dos elementos de los cuales hay
que preocuparnos tenemos el hidrógeno de
este lado mientras que de este otro lado
tenemos el helio así que vamos a empezar
con el hidrógeno verdad el número
atómico del hidrógeno es 1 así que si
tenemos un número atómico de 1 eso
significa que para el hidrógeno tenemos
un protón tenemos un protón para el
hidrógeno y en un átomo neutral el
número de protones tiene que ser igual
al número de electrones así que si
tenemos un protón aquí debe haber
también un electrón muy bien así que
nuestro objetivo es escribir una
configuración electrónica para este
electrón del hidrógeno y vamos a
utilizar el principio de fútbol o algo
así se pronuncia verdad que en realidad
es una palabra relacionada con la
palabra construir verdad porque
justamente vamos a escribir las
configuraciones electrónicas
en la mejor forma de construir un átomo
así que vamos a pensar cómo poner los
electrones ok solo tenemos que
preocuparnos por un electrón así que
pensemos cuál es el mejor lugar para
poner a este electrón que tenemos aquí
en el hidrógeno ok y queremos poner ese
electrón tan cerca como nos sea posible
del núcleo verdad para poder maximizar
la fuerza de atracción entre la carga
positiva y la carga negativa así que de
ahí que el electrón tiene que estar en
el nivel más bajo de energía posible y
eso es únicamente cuando n es igual a 1
verdad ya hemos hablado de los números
cuánticos en vídeos anteriores y 100 es
igual a 1 entonces solo tenemos un valor
posible para el de verdad y esto es 0 si
él es igual a 0 entonces también tenemos
solo un único valor posible para ml
verdad así que el número y el número
magnet perdón el el número cuántico
magnético ese tiene que ser igual a 0
muy bien tiene que ser igual a cero así
que él tiene que ser igual a cero y
estamos entonces hablando de un
orbitales y esto nos dice cuántas
orientaciones puede tener así que
tenemos sólo un valor para las
orientaciones de nuestro orbital es
verdad y el orbital s tiene una forma
más o menos esférica verdad tiene una
forma más o menos esférica así que en
esta esfera en este volumen
tridimensional de aquí este es el lugar
digamos que es más más común de
encontrar el electrón verdad es la
región que va a preferir este electrón
así que el electrón para el hidrógeno va
a estar en un orbitales y un orbital ese
es el primer nivel de energía así que
vamos a escribir la configuración el
electrón
así que vamos a escribir la
configuración electrónica como 1 s 1
verdad y vamos a hablar de qué es lo que
significa todo esto este 1 que tenemos
por aquí este 1 que tenemos digamos del
lado izquierdo nos dice cuál es el nivel
de energía verdad la capa n es igual a 1
s nos dice que el electrón para el
hidrógeno va en un orbital ese y este
súper índice que tenemos aquí nos dice
cuántos electrones se encuentran en
dicho orbital y aquí por supuesto
estamos hablando de sólo un electrón así
que s tenemos 1s uno muy bien 1s uno
significa que tenemos un electrón en un
orbital es de verdad en el primer nivel
de energía ahora hay otra forma de
escribir la configuración electrónica o
digamos quizás podría ser dibujarlo y
esta es la anotación o se le conoce como
la anotación orbital verdad dibujamos
simplemente una
dibujamos una línea aquí que representa
un orbital y estamos hablando de un
orbital s en el primer nivel de energía
entonces ponemos 1s y ponemos el
electrón del hidrógeno en ese orbital s
verdad en este orbital ese y digamos que
este electrón entra con un spin orbital
hacia arriba muy bien así que esta
flecha apuntando hacia arriba representa
un electrón con un spin hacia arriba así
que el cuarto número cuántico verdad que
es m s tendrá que ser igual a un medio
positivo verdad eso es un spin de un
medio positivo así que aquí tenemos dos
formas esencialmente similares de
escribir la configuración electrónica 1
s 1 o podríamos de hecho vamos a
marcarlos tenemos este el 1 s 1 o
también podríamos dibujarlo con la
anotación orbital muy bien muy bien
ahora vamos a movernos con el helio
vámonos con el helio que tiene un número
atómico de 2 verdad en un número atómico
de 2 eso significa que hay dos protones
y 2 electrones así que hay que
considerar simplemente dos electrones
tenemos 2 electrones de los cuales
preocuparnos y aún seguimos en la
primera capa verdad seguimos en el
primer nivel de energía así que n es
igual a 1 verdad y 100 es igual a 1 l
tiene que ser igual a 0 y por supuesto
como en el caso anterior
ml también tiene que ser igual a cero
así que aún estamos hablando de un
orbital s en el primer nivel de energía
verdad así que todavía todavía estamos
hablando de un orbital s en el primer
nivel de energía para el helio muy bien
así que obtenemos un orbital s en el
primer nivel de energía para el helio y
aquí tenemos 2 electrones verdad así que
tenemos un orbital s con 2 electrones en
el primer nivel de energía así que
podríamos dibujar el primer electrón
para el él es más vamos a dibujar su
vamos a dibujar
la notación orbital aquí verdad
podríamos dibujar tenemos el 1s tenemos
el primer electrón con un spin hacia
arriba y el segundo electrón para el
helio tendrá un spin hacia abajo verdad
aquí tenemos la pareja de spin es uno va
hacia arriba uno va hacia abajo y por
qué tendría que ser así bueno vamos a
vamos a escribir lo siguiente voy a
escribir que para este electrón el que
obtiene una espina hacia abajo su ms el
valor de ms tiene que ser menos un medio
un medio negativo para ese spin y la
razón de por qué tiene que ser de esta
forma es por el principio de exclusión
de poli verdad que nos dice que dos
electrones en un átomo no pueden tener
los mismos cuatro números cuánticos muy
bien y si pensamos en este primer
electrón con una espina hacia arriba
pues en realidad sus números cuánticos
corresponden justamente a los que ya
habíamos escrito en el hidrógeno verdad
es tiene un n igual a 1 el igual a cero
de igual a 0 y ms igual a más un medio
verdad y en vez de reescribir lo
simplemente lo sé circulado ahora si
pensamos en este spin que va hacia abajo
no puede tener el mismo número de perdón
no puede tener los cuatro mismos números
cuánticos que en el caso anterior por el
principio de exclusión de paul y así que
como sigue teniendo n igual a 1 tiene l
igual a 0 y ml igual a 0 entonces el
único que puede cambiar es ms y tiene
que ser un medio negativo esta es la
razón por la cual lo escribimos como un
medio negativo y por lo tanto su spin va
hacia abajo y ahí tenemos los dos
electrones en el helio verdad tienen un
conjunto distinto de los cuatro números
cuánticos verdad y difieren justamente
por el último número cuántico y esa es
la idea central del principio de
exclusión de pobre y como consecuencia
del principio de exclusión de paul y un
orbital puede contener un máximo de 2
electrones porque hemos agotado todas
las posibles combinaciones
números cuánticos y los hemos usado
completamente así que nuestro orbital s
está completamente lleno y también
podríamos escribir la configuración
electrónica verdad del helio como 1s dos
verdad que significa el 1 nuevamente que
estamos en el primer nivel de energía
estamos en el primer nivel de energía si
la s significa que estamos en 1 orbital
ese y el 2
significa que hay 2 electrones en ese
orbital verdad en dicho orbital es así
que como ya tenemos 2 electrones en el
orbital ese ya no podemos ajustar más
electrones y por eso es que la primera
capa ya está cerrada tenemos una capa
completamente llena y no hay más
orbitales para este primer nivel de
energía si quisiéramos agregar otro
electrón tendríamos que movernos a la
siguiente capa y eso nos llevaría al
segundo periodo de la tabla periódica